so one time i was hanging out my niece  madison and at the time she was like six  or something like that right and uh we  were we were playing uh nintendo and i  was uh like going in hard on it i wasn't  giving her any leeway i was dominating  and i was like what's the matter huh you  know whatever and then she gets up at  one point and she just i saw the steam  she's six six eight she gets up and she  throws the remote  and she goes you know what uncle sal  you're boring  [Laughter]  and then she  like walked she stormed out  so she's like i have to i had to get him  back and she was looking for a mic drop  and her mic dropped she found that  you're bored  and i left i just kept laughing so hard  i'm like i'm boring  it's such a funny thing to say to  someone and then like later that night  when i was trying to go to sleep  i was like why would she say that  like why where did she even get that  like  why would you say that about me because  i'm not boring